the Joe Rogan experience is this some
good some good [ __ ] about in today's
cars - right by itself yeah yeah yeah
been in the Tesla there freak-outs man
you'll freak you out
look you driving that thing oh my god
you they fast this [ __ ] it's ridiculous
right did you ever drive one yeah dude
the crazy thing about the Tesla's is
it's like a race car it's like yeah and
you'd be waiting for they'd be like like
but it don't never change gears it's
just straight like that it's so fast
doesn't make sense
it's like a race car it's like a time
machine it's like it compresses time
like there's a certain amount of time in
a normal car you feel like you have to
go there's a certain amount of time that
lets take place for it and get in front
of that guy and then get over here and
then get to the on ramp with a Tesla you
just go shoot you're there it's like
time expresses yes 0 to 60 and 2.4
seconds damn you never even felt
anything like it it's a goddamn roller
coaster ride so you're pinned to your
seat it's just going ya know like [ __ ]
and they're making a faster one there go
one's gonna be 1.9 the Roadster that
really slick looking little tiny one
there ridiculous that's the future yeah
I got a demon dodge demon oh those are
nice it's fun that's a fun [ __ ] it was
that like 800 horsepower
I think 909 something after anything
over 7 they may will sign my rights away
really
you got sign all these papers talking
about if you die or get seriously
injured and can't nobody else come back
and so on all our crazy [ __ ] what a car
so fast they letting you know like you
know you can get real life [ __ ] up it
do they make those in a stick shift or
is it just an automatic uh oh no I got
our man it's a crazy amount of power by
thing I think nowadays you you got the
parameters yeah yeah Auto shifters
that's cute where you can put a manual
shift in with your left foot in the
clutch and shifting gears that you're
right that's like part of the whole
muscle car thing
all right yeah yeah part of the old
school thing you want to mold school
automatic it seems silly you know just
think school yeah that's true it's way
faster oh it's way faster cars today
away faster period and they're all gonna
be electric within ten years they're
just so much better
they there's so much faster right if
this is always they can figure out how
to make it charge quick that's the thing
the gas has you just pulling the gas
station 10 minutes later you got a full
tank right so your cart charges up
yeah every tape let's take a good solid
six or seven hours if it's dead if it's
almost dead it'll take like six or seven
hours at a super I have a supercharger
to normally it might take twelve like
with a regular outlet yeah it takes a
long time yeah so if you pull into like
one of those superchargers I think they
can get you up to like 80% in like an
hour to first charge the first 80% quick
pretty quick so you could do that it's
like transfer gas yeah yeah you pay for
it yeah use a credit card I got that one
yeah I seen them there but the airport's
free you plug in at the airport and it's
free
it's uh it's a weird experience man
because I love the sound of engines but
that car makes them all look stupid yeah
they all seem dumb yeah I got a had that
muscle muscle it's fun yeah I'm what you
get you can't burn out in it no there's
no burning out just go it makes it noise
like this we like it doesn't make any
noise it doesn't like just takes off
yeah doesn't even seem real I like them
the inside is crazy with the big screen
touchscreen and ya know the great dope
you just look like you're in a
futuristic it feels like you're in the
futuristic